after spending some time with red crow I
can say that the latest Japan themed DLC
ads in my opinion one good operator a
great map and doesn't fix one of my
biggest problems with siege as a
tactical shooter he claimed first up hey
vana she's a great new addition to the
attackers / gadget a 40-millimeter
grenade launcher cuts horizontal slits
and heavy barricades combining ash's
range with thermite's unique exothermic
charges players have always had a few
maps where they could reliably break
walls over the tops of heavy barricades
and fire into rooms but now this can be
done on any map countering this is still
mutes jammers and bandits Electrify
ability combined with Havana's type 89
rifle and supernova shotgun she's great
at opening up barricaded rooms for the
rest of her team
five second in terms of the games
fortifying meta the general idea is
still that a good defending team will
bring mute and bandit to keep attackers
from going through their heavy
reinforced walls and a good attacking
team will bring factor with his EMP
grenade to destroy their gadgets and
then thermite or Habana to get through
the walls what the defenders get in red
crow is echo a man with a fairly weak
suppressed mp5 SD and also a supernova
shotgun as well as a drone that
disorients people but after being hit by
this drone while attacking several times
and still managing to mow down the
opposing team and left scratching my
head as to what is good for especially
if the choice is not to pick one of the
much stronger defenders with armor
reinforced barricades jammers or the
ability to see players heartbeats
through walls one glaring problem with
siege that red crow doesn't address his
peakers advantage any game that results
in a player doing this has something
that needs to be changed with its core
mechanics and if you think that guy just
sucks watch pro league players do it
peakers advantages we're stationary
player doesn't see a player strafing
back and forth on a corner until they're
dead and staring at a kill cam that
doesn't reflect what they saw or in this
case didn't see for a game that's
supposed to be tactical and about siege
having systems that don't give the
advantage to the well entrench
stationary player kills good planning in
favor of running gun tactics running gun
tactics in turn make much of the gadgets
in the game too slow to bother with an
easy fix for this would be to increase
move and shoot penalties or preferably
at a ready up timer so that players have
a delay from sprinting to being able to
shoot one thing red crow could be fixing
for siege is not enough maps per DLC one
free map every few months hasn't been
enough to keep the game interesting when
competing with juggernauts like
battlefield 1 titanfall 2 and Call of
Duty infinite warfare
even though skyscraper is a good map
without more to play there's just not a
lot to stay for Ubisoft has confirmed a
second map Bartlett University is coming
in an undated upcoming five pointy patch
this map was showcased at the end of the
main game situations as article 5 and
was highly requested by fans now that
year 2 for Rainbow six siege is
confirmed what do you want to see out of
the game
would you like you to slow back down and
become more tactical or do you like the
running gun per League direction that it
going in leave your pithy comments below
and for more coverage of Rainbow six
each stay tuned to game spot calm
you